just weeks after Russian president
President Vladimir Putin announced a
partial military mobilization new
recruits are now arriving on the front
lines in Ukraine but how well equipped
are these troops to fight Ukraine's
forces which appear to be continuing
their Advance through Russia's lines
DW's Kilian Bayer reports that while
Moscow may be able to enlist hundreds of
thousands of civilians it doesn't seem
to be able to supply them with enough
weapons clothes ammunition and even food
everything
Rusty weapons and squalid conditions
these are just some of the images that
have been circulating on Russian social
media and telegram chats showing the
things that mobilized Russian men are
having to deal with
and it expands and stops the bleeding
foreign
these pictures also from telegram
allegedly show residents bringing
supplies to a military base in Novo
subersk
moscow's mobilization efforts are not
going to plan
soldiers are missing sleeping bags food
and medical equipment
we found groups on Russian social media
where relatives of Russian soldiers are
sharing pictures of the equipment they
are sending to the front
we reached out to Russian soldiers but
couldn't get any to appear on camera for
an interview when asked why they are
going to war one of them replied
I'm not looking into the causes of this
war if I was mobilized it means that my
motherland needs me I am a simple
Soldier the question why and what for is
not my responsibility
Russian lawyer Max ayonichev says social
conditioning like this dates back to
Soviet times and is part of the problem
the majority of Russian people are not
ready to go to war
but there's a willingness to rely on the
government's decisions because there is
a belief that authorities know better
the people don't think critically thus
they don't understand when the
government is using them as Cannon
father
it's been three weeks since Russian
President Putin announced a partial
mobilization
since then hundreds of thousands more
Russian families have been drawn into
the war
now Russian officials say the
mobilization aims to draft as many as
300 000 men it's estimated that two
hundred thousand have already been
called up many are trying to flee to
avoid serving let's take a look now at
where they're actually going
kazakhstan's interior Minister said more
than 200 000 Russians have entered his
country since the colab order three
weeks ago in Georgia the interior
Ministry reported nearly 69 000 Russians
arriving in the same short time period
the European Union has also seen an
influx of Russians since Putin's order
despite visa restrictions that make it
much more difficult to enter the EU the
board agency frontex says at least 144
000 have entered but figures only show
total arrivals not explaining why they
traveled other countries also report an
uptick in Russian arrivals more most
noteworthy here are Israel Armenia and
turkey sanctions and other travel
restrictions mean Russians face many
hurdles when trying to exit their
country and we can now speak to someone
who actually managed to flee the call up
his name is Pavel he's a Russian who
recently left his home country and for
his own safety we are not giving away
his full name but we can tell you that
he is in Kazakhstan right now Pablo
thank you very much for joining us here
on on DW news uh just explain to us why
did you go why did you leave
well
um first uh because of the draft holders
uh and I'm not P for any army whatsoever
I didn't serve I don't have any
intentions to serve in an army in the
world
so and Russia drafts many people even
those that are not fit to live in modern
Russian cities
so how explain to us briefly explain to
us briefly how hard was it for you to
leave Russia
ah when I left it wasn't as hard as the
maybe now but uh on near the border
there was a big traffic jam we stayed up
to 19 or 20 hours
it was several kilometers long
and it was very cold during that time
so how's your life now
um well uh I'm right now I'm in
Kazakhstan it's a beautiful great
country I never imagined I
I will be here
um but I did want to go here sometime
it's sadly that
um it had to be the draft order for me
to to be here
so the people are very responsive very
hospitable
um it's just great
so if you look to the Future how do you
see your life developing there in
Kazakhstan I mean this can go on for
quite some time and do you think you'll
be able to return to Russia
um
well frankly I don't have any intentions
of returning to Russia as me and my my
wife who stays in Russia still who I
love dearly um we planned to go to
Israel and just our plans are moved just
a bit
so Israel is your ultimate goal is it
yeah yeah okay
Pablo thank you very much
for speaking with us and good luck to
have me
bye
and now to a tale of survival from
Russia's barrage of airstrikes on Keith
earlier this week you may remember
seeing images of a pedestrian glass
Bridge a key of land landmark and of the
blast that nearly destroyed it our
correspondent Matthias Berling I met up
with a man who was on that bridge at the
exact moment of impact and he had a very
narrow Escape
every morning before work
takes a walk through kiev's Riverside
Parks across a Scenic glass Bridge built
a few years ago
last Monday was no exception it was an
extraordinary beautiful autumn day
I was standing on that balcony over
there
it was 18 minutes past eight in the
morning
that was the day Putin launched more
than 80 missiles at Ukraine surveillance
cameras caught the moment
I was standing at the other side of the
bridge opposite the explosion near that
bench and the pressure wave from the
explosion went underneath
the rocket hit just next to the bridge
on the walkway in the park
three days later the crater the rocket
left has already been filled in
workers are repairing the rest of the
damage the bridge is slightly damaged
and closed off to the public for now
hey man you're famous now
the video of him on the bridge went
viral Ukrainian TV reported him
wish you a guardian angel
o says he has recovered well from the
shock
you just start to Value life more you
understand that you need to live every
day to its fullest and not to put things
off until later
foreign
[Music]
just after the blast he went to his
office like any other day